hey up here astroboy if you think you
can just show up and take our top prize
spots you're wrong
Toy Story floor is everything we wanted
and more and to top it all off it's
filled to the brim with Easter eggs and
references we're not kidding around Toy
Story 4 literally has more Easter eggs
than any other Pixar film keep watching
to find out how Duke KABOOOM managed to
slip in a matrix quote without anyone
noticing duke kaboom Canada's greatest
stuntman yeah Jerry's game no one plays
a better game of chess than Pixar's very
own Jerry from the short film
Jerry's game this old timers picture can
be spotted in second chance antique
store the shop owner Margaret has
Jerry's picture pinned behind the store
counter dogs playing poker second chance
antique shop is filled with Easter eggs
and more at first we saw what looked
like a regular old dogs playing poker
portrait but at second glance we
realized that the portrait was of
Charles Muntz
and his dogs from the classic movie up
the old poultry palace this one was
super hard to spot but there's a poster
of ye olde poultry palace hiding in
plain view in the antique shop for those
of you who aren't familiar with poultry
palace it's a fast food chain that was
featured in Toy Story toon small fry I
used to work at poultry palace the grape
soda calf in the scene where we first
see Bo Peep super rad skunk ride we see
her sheep looting a grape soda cap this
is the same cap Carl gave to Russell at
the end of up you know the one his late
wife Ellie gave to him film reels Woody
and Beau used an 8 millimeter film
projector to rescue four key from Gabby
Gabby and her terrifying henchmen if you
look closely you can see a stack of film
reels right next to the projector these
film reels include dozens of Pixar
shorts now that's what we call a basket
of Easter eggs being Vaughn's rocket
although it's hard to catch up first
second chance antiques is also selling
Bing bongs rocket from the movie inside
out it's collecting dust on a shelf in
the background
Eggman moving company if you saw an egg
man moving company poster in the antique
shop then you might have unknowingly
discovered a mini easter egg production
designer Ralph Eggleston worked on the
first Toy Story movie and his nickname
is Eggman so this poster was set up to
pay
some homage cocoa Easter eggs el Sun de
la Cruz might be evil but boy can he
sing did you guys notice the cocoa
antagonists record in the antique shop
it was displayed on an old record player
triple dent who could forget the catchy
triple done jingle from inside out not
Riley that's for sure their ever so
popular gum brand even managed to make
an appearance in the antique shop but
this time it appeared as a poster
instead of a commercial Dino coke gasps
Bonnie's family stops at a Dinoco gas
station to fuel up during the road trip
this subtle Easter Egg wasn't too
visible but that didn't stop some fans
from pointing it out Coco's guitar
we were so distracted by bunny ducky and
buzzes hilarious banter that we almost
missed an Easter egg or two come on help
me get out of here to the left of the
screen is a very familiar looking guitar
you guessed it it's a version of Coco's
most prized possession the Mickey Mouse
phone if you are wondering why would II
chose to pretend to be a telephone when
Margaret nearly spotted him in the
antique shop you're not alone this
Easter egg was for the older crowd woody
was pretending to be a classic Mickey
Mouse phone from the 70s and 80s second
chances address it's no big secret that
Pixar Animation Studios managed to sneak
in their headquarters address into the
film second chances door number is 1200
which is the same as Pixar's Toy Story
clouds we all know and love the familiar
Toy Story clouds these clouds first
appeared on Andy's bedroom wallpaper
when we catch a glimpse of them in
Bonnie's room we're happy to see that
she's keeping the tradition tin toy we
get to see just how popular Beau is with
the second-chance toys when she steps
into the pinball machine during the
scene the protagonist from Pixar short
film tin toy can be spotted in the
background there's a name on my boot
Bonnie isn't one to skimp out when it
comes to tradition which is why she
labels her toys just like Andy once did
did you guys notice how Woody's boot had
Bonnie written on it we'd much rather
have a name on her boot than a snake
inside of it
Space Odyssey reference thanks to Woody
Buzz finally knows how to listen to the
little voice inside of him let's get our
parts together one of his newest
catchphrases is open the pod bay doors
which is actually a famous line
belonging to Stanley Kubrick's sci-fi
film
a space odyssey.the et reference at the
end of Toy Story 4 do kaboom manages to
make an impossible jump well almost
but if he hadn't hit his head it would
have been the perfect stunt so let's
give him a bit of credit this epic
moment had an ET reference written all
over it
Dux soared through the night sky and
across a full moon just like et once did
before him matrix reference this easter
egg happened during a post-credits scene
so not everyone had a chance to see it
if you don't know it already do kaboom
is voiced by the legendary Keanu Reeves
who starred in The Matrix his character
neo says whoa during a particularly
mind-blowing scene so we're not too
surprised that Pixar chose to sneak this
super popular line into their movie so
how many of these Easter eggs and
references did you spot out let us know
in the comments section and while you're
at it tell us who your favorite new Toy
Story character is let's compile and
that's a wrap
give this video a big thumbs up if you
think woody and Bo Peep are relationship
goals and be sure to subscribe to the
themes for more videos like this one
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]